COUNTRY, STOP IT TONIGHT.
>> Sean: DAN BONGINO, PAT
BRONSON DOMINIC BROSNAN.
THE MYSTERIOUS APPEARANCE, GET
THIS, PILE OF BRICKS, LITERALLY
BEING STATIONED NEAR THE SITES
OF WHERE THESE PROTESTS AND
RIOTS ULTIMATELY BECOME.
THEY ARE STAGING IT.
JOINING US NOW TO REPORT ANOTHER
DISTURBING STORY, HE’S IN OUR
WEST COAST BARROW TONIGHT, CHIEF
BREAKING NEWS CORRESPONDENT
TRACE GALLAGHER.
SO THEY ARE LITERALLY STAGING
WEAPONS THAT THEY’RE GOING TO
USE THAT EVENING TO THROW THE
BRICKS OF THE COPS, TRACE, IS
THAT HOW WE INTERPRET THAT?
THAT’S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> THAT’S THE BELIEF.
YOU HAVE THESE PILES OF BRICKS
AND ROCKS SHOWING UP NEAR THE
VARIOUS PROTESTS SITES.
FAYETTEVILLE, NORTH CAROLINA,
KANSAS CITY, DALLAS, NONE OF
THEM ARE IN YOUR CONSTRUCTION
AREAS, LEADING MANY TO ASSUME
THE BRICKS WERE PLANTED BY
OUTSIDE AGITATORS PACIFICALLY TO
STIR UP TROUBLE.
IN FACT, THE NEW YORK POLICE
DEPARTMENT SAYS HAS EVIDENCE
THAT ANARCHIST GROUPS WERE
PUSHING THE PROTESTS TOWARDS
VIOLENCE AND VANDALISM.
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS SAY THE VIOLENCE
POINTS TO FAR LEFT GROUPS LIKE
NT FIVE.
OTHERS SAY FAR RIGHT GROUPS
MIGHT ALSO BE INVOLVED.
MANY OF THE LOOTERS DON’T NEED
TO BE SUPPLIED WITH BRICKS AND
ROCKS BECAUSE THEY SHOW UP WITH
THEIR OWN TOOLS IN HAND, WELL
PREPARED TO DESTROY PROPERTY.
POLICE IN MINNEAPOLIS ALSO FOUND
CACHES OF STOLEN VEHICLES AND
INCENDIARY DEVICES IN AREAS
WHERE NUMEROUS FIRES HAD BROKEN
OUT AND IN BALTIMORE, THERE’S
EVIDENCE OF DOUBLE DANGER.
POLICE HAVE BEEN SWEEPING THE
DOWNTOWN AREA AFTER, GET THIS,
FINDING BOTH BRICKS AND BOTTLES
WITH POTENTIAL ACCELERANTS
ALREADY INSIDE THEM.
BUT INSTEAD OF BEING LEFT OUT AN
OPEN PASS, THESE POTENTIAL
WEAPONS ARE KIND OF BEING HIDDEN
IN SMALL AREAS, THOUGH IT’S
UNCLEAR IF THEY ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PROTESTS OR GROUPS ON